il ya quelques semaines agence
européenne de médecine a déclaré que les
vaccins astrazeneca contre locaux vite
19 sont sûrs et efficaces
l'agencé a toutefois rajouter qu'elle ne
peut pas exclure définitivement un lien
avec des troubles de la coagulation rare
voilà une formulation qui a le don de
m'agacer je ne suis pas le seul
comme on a longuement déjà parlé dans
cette série sur le bail kahnisme la
communauté des statisticiens et de
nombreux scientifiques se sont
massivement opposés publiquement contre
cette façon de parler de la science avec
notamment un article publié dans nature
est cosigné par plus de 800
scientifiques en effet imaginer que la
science est un tribunal qu'il soit est
en cours de délibération soit a émis un
verdict définitif sur l'existence d'un
effet c'est ce qu'on peut appeler le
sophisme de la réfutation
c'est en tout cas une vision très
erronée de la manière dont la science
est pratiqué dans les laboratoires et
c'est une ambition très indésirable de
la manière dont la science devrait
fonctionner
la science ne fonctionne pas par rocher
spectaculaire de théorie et si elle
fonctionnait comme cela elle serait
vouée à commettre un nombre monumental
d'erreurs graves
en effet comme l'expliqué si bien floue
en born les données en général et les
tests en particulier ne détermine pas ce
qu'il faut conclure il ne détermine pas
non plus ce qu'il faut croire les
données devraient mettre à jour nos
croyances ou dit autrement
selon le bail à nice mme en tout cas la
science devrait surtout être cumulatives
chaque donnée devrait s'ajouter à tout
un corpus de milliards de données voire
de milliards de milliards de données qui
ensemble détermine ce qui est adéquat de
croire mais surtout malgré tout cette
montagne de données dont de très
nombreux cas sinon la quasi totalité des
cas il n'y aura généralement pas lieu de
conclure quoi que ce soit de manière
déterministe malgré toutes ces données
il restera un multivers bayésiens
gigantesque des possibles dès lors il
faut surtout accepter l'incertitude
comme l'expliquent les statisticiens
dans une revue spéciale dédiée à
l'épistémologie et aux statistiques
en particulier il faut raisonner avec
l'incertitude et prendre des décisions
sous incertitudes et non pas attendre le
jour où on saura et dans le cas des
effets secondaires du vaccin
astrazeneca pour prendre des mesures
sous d'incertitude la question
pertinente est en fait pas du tout
l'existence d'un lien entre les vaccins
astrazeneca et des troubles de
coagulation pour prendre une décision
dans ce cas ce qui importe notamment dès
lors que de l'os
intitulé est en jeu et en médecine c'est
essentiellement toujours le cas ce qui
importe c'est la fameuse balance
risque/bénéfice ou pour parler en termes
bayésiens le calcul contrat factuelle en
particulier ces considérations nous
invite à remplacer la question du rejet
d'hypothèses qui est en fait une
question souvent très pertinentes par la
question détail des faits probable
j'aimerais que ce site devienne un
réflexe chez vous à chaque fois que vous
lisez existence d'un lien vous devrez
vous dire mais aux affiches qui est
important est peut être ce sont les
têtes des faits probable est pas le
rejet de cette hypothèse nul bord d'être
bien sûr je voudrais te dire ça dans
votre tête et surtout ne pas le dire de
façon agressive et un interlocuteur
parce que à chaque de bâton mieux et
tout ça en particulier dans le cas des
vaccins astrazeneca
il existe désormais une montagne de
données qui permettent en fait d'avoir
une estimation raisonnable de la taille
des effets probables du vaccin sur les
troubles de coagulation
en effet des millions de personnes à
travers le monde ont été vaccinés et
seulement quelques dizaines de cas de
troubles de coagulation ont été
rapportés bon bien sûr c'est un chiffre
sous-estimé puisqu'elles sont des cas de
troubles de coagulation qui n'ont pas
été rapportés mais ça fait quand même
très peu en particulier ceux ci
correspond tout à fait à l'ordre de
grandeur de ce qui serait attendu pour
des personnes qui n'ont pas été vaccinés
puisque ces troubles affectent de toute
façon de nombreuses personnes âgées
sachant cela on peut affirmer que tout
effets du vaccin astrazeneca sur les
troubles de coagulation est alors
nécessairement très très très faible de
l'ordre de peut-être 10 par million sont
par millions au grand max en particulier
ceux ci semblent beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus faible que les risque de
formes graves de coheed 19 contre
lesquels astrazeneca est d'ailleurs très
efficace
aujourd'hui j'aimerais insister
davantage sur la manière de mettre à
jour des crédences sur les tailles des
faits probable d'un traitement comme on
va le voir il s'agit d'une danse comme
celle de la courbe illustré à l'écran
d'ici la fin de la vidéo
j'aimerais que vous compreniez ce qui se
passe à l'écran et en quoi il s'agit
d'une bien meilleure description de
l'étendue de notre ignorance et du
développement de nos connaissances que
les phrases du genre on ne peut pas
exclure l'existence d'un effet alors on
a déjà parlé de danse des créances dans
l'épisode notamment sur les curseurs de
turing cependant comme on l'a vu ces
curseurs ne sont en fait visualisables
uniquement que pour comparer deux
théories concurrentes comme la taille
l'effet est nul et la taille des faits
est égal à 1
mais en général les tailles des faits
peuvent prendre des valeurs continue
ainsi on a envie de dire que la
probabilité pour une personne vaccinée
d'acquérir des troubles de coagulation
est un nombre réel entre 0 et or
mais ce nombre peut a priori prendre
n'importe quelle valeur entre 0 et 1
or chaque nombre x entre 0 et 1 définit
sa propre théorie la taille des faits
est égal à x
on a donc ici un continuum de théorie à
comparer en fait pour aujourd'hui pour
encore plus simplifié le problème je
vous propose de mesurer une tête et fait
encore plus continuent comme par exemple
l'intensité d'une douleur ou le nombre
de jours de récupération
on va supposer que chaque personne ayant
subi un traitement rapporte alors un
niveau d'intensité de douleur ou un
nombre de jours de récupération
nécessaire
ce qu'on va essayer d'estimer maintenant
c'est la taille des faits probable
moyenne sur l'ensemble de la population
qu'elle est l'intensité de douleurs
moyenne suite au traitement
l'intérêt de ce problème c'est qu'ils se
prêtent particulièrement bien alain côté
une mobilisation très simple et surtout
à des calculs bayésiens exact facilement
visualisables va en particulier
considérer le modèle suivant re supposer
que pour chaque individu
l'intensité de sa douleur des vies de la
douleur moyenne avec une erreur qui suit
une loi normale variations individuelles
est alors couramment appelé le bruit
alors que la douleur moyenne est souvent
appelé le signal du pour aujourd'hui on
va même supposer qu'on connaît l'ampleur
du bruit cependant on va supposer qu'on
ignore la valeur du signal
c'est à dire la douleur moyenne due au
traitement et donc notre but est de
trouver le signal sachant qu'il y a un
bruit dont on connaît l'ampleur typique
alors en bon bayésiens ce qu'on va faire
maintenant c'est des clercs notre
ignorance sur la valeur du signal
par une crédence pour chaque théorie on
va signer une probabilité a priori sur
cette théorie
ainsi pour la théorie la douleur moyenne
est égal à 1,2 sur une échelle de 0 à 10
on va assigner une certaine créé lance
alors à priori ça va être très laborieux
de faire cela puisqu'on a vu qu'il ya en
fait un continuum de théorie et il
faudra signer une crédence à chacune de
ces théories une solution pour adresser
cette difficulté est en fait de
considérer toute une courbe qui décrit
une autre incertitude
et pour faire simple on va considérer
une courbe en cloche qui suit la loi
normale
ainsi dans ce cas ça revient à dire
qu'on ne sais absolument pas si l'effet
va être plutôt positif ou négatif
autrement dit on ne sait pas si ça va
causer ou réduire nos douleurs
l'étalement de la courbe décrit par
ailleurs l'étendue de notre ignorance
plus la courbe et aplatit plus on
envisage la possibilité de modification
intense de la douleur al'inverse si la
courbe est très concentré en un point
ça veut dire qu'on est quasiment sûr que
la taille des faits est quasiment égale
au point en question une dernière petite
précision avant de voir comment les
données vous faire danser les crédences
noter qu'il y a 2 aléatoire distincts
dans notre modèle d'un côté il ya
l'étendue de notre ignorance décrite par
l'étalement des crédences 7 aléatoire
décrit une autre incertitude sur notre
connaissance et de l'autre côté il ya la
variation entre les sujets soumis au
traitement qui va déterminer à quel
point de la douleur d'un individu
particulier peut dévier de la valeur
moyenne
cette variation interpersonnelles peut
aussi être interprétée comme du bruit
dans les données sachant la vraie taille
des faits moyenne ou dit encore
autrement ce second alia et
l'incertitude de chaque théorie la
douleur moyenne est égal à x il ya ainsi
une incertitude de chaque théorie et une
méta incertitudes sur quelle théorie et
plus juste on parle aussi parfois de
modèles bayésiens l'hiérarchie qu
ok on y est on va
faire danser les clés danse et se
secouer le postérieur pour cette
simulation vous voyez ici la vraie
taille des faits une autre incertitude
initiale sur cette taille des faits
imaginez maintenant qu'on collecte des
données au fur et à mesure dans cette
simulation
chaque donnée tirée au hasard comme
étant la vraie ta défaite plus le bruit
aléatoire comme vous le voyez à chaque
nouvelle donne et les crédences vont se
déplacer pour se rapprocher de la
données collectées
je vais pas entrer dans les détails de
comment ça fonctionne mais sachez que
dans cette simulation la danse des
créances obéit rigoureusement aux lois
des probabilités importe la formule deux
pays comme vous le voyez la forme de
baisses ne va pas faire sauter
directement les crédences sur la données
collectées et ça c'est parce que chaque
données brutes et est du coup chaque
donnée n'informe que partiellement sur
la valeur de la brette ait des faits
cependant donné après donner nos
crédence temps danse et danse et se
secoue le postérieur
alors quand les données sont peu [ __ ]
cette convergence est très rapide comme
vous voyez ici dans ce cas très peu de
données suffisent à estimer très
correctement les tiac effet probable
cependant ça c'était un cas où les
données étaient très peu brute et quand
les données sont très brut et dans parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de variance
interpersonnelles l'écrit dans une terre
des pas de danse beaucoup plus discret
par ailleurs l'ignorance va se réduire
beaucoup plus lentement
comme vous le voyez ici les crédences
reste longtemps très étendue nous se
déplace que très lentement
une façon peut être perturbant les
crédences ont en fait souvent
temporairement s'éloigner de la vraie
taille des faits l'apprentissage est
dense et 7 ans n'est absolument pas
monotone
elle peut passer par des phases où la
vraie taille des faits est mal estimées
à cause des fluctuations statistiques
dans les données montrent d'ailleurs
bien observé en suivant du regard un
internat d'excellence à 90%
cet intervalle peut très bien
initialement contenir la bataille des
faits et to tatou sont éloignés au point
que la brette à des fêtes sortie de cet
intervalle avant que plus tard cet
intervalle reviennent à nouveau sur la
brèche a été fait ces exemples montrent
aussi à quel point le rejet de
l'hypothèse nu
et délicat il était en effet tentant de
vouloir rejeter cette hypothèse quand la
barre orange ne contient plus
l'hypothèse nu il peut par exemple être
ici est le fait que contenir 0 dans
l'intervalle mais à bien y réfléchir
vouloir rejeter cette hypothèse nul
c'est surtout une mauvaise question à se
poser quand il s'agit de prendre une
décision qui va dépendre de la taille
des faits du traitement et c'est ce qui
est important selon une analyse
risque/bénéfice ce qu'il faut surveiller
ce sont davantage les cailles des faits
aubade et ça ça nécessite de tenir
compte de l'ensemble des crédences en
fait ce qui me semble le plus important
à retenir de ces simulations
ce que je trouve vraiment magnifique
dans ces six nations c'est qu'elle
illustre à merveille le fait au moins
dans le cadre du mécanisme
l'apprentissage est une danse tous les
pas de danse ne vont pas aller dans le
même sens mais pas à pas la danse permet
de progresser et de réduire l'étendue de
notre ignorance
[Musique]
pour finir cette vidéo que j'aimerais
insister sur le fait que les simulations
que je vous ai montré ont surtout un
rôle illustratif en particulier elles
décrivent le paysagisme dans un cas très
particulier est extrêmement simple
en pratique la danse des crédences est
une symphonie beaucoup plus complexe
orchestrée en premier lieu il faut
l'adapter à différents cas d'application
dans le cas par exemple de mesurer
l'état des faits en tant que probabilité
d'un événement grave et loi normale
qu'on a utilisées ne sont pas adaptés
parfois on se base à nice mme se prête
aussi très bien à ce cas via notamment
la loi bêta pneus mentionné dans la
vidéo avec michael et donc je finirai
forcément de parler dans cette série
notamment parce que c'est dû aux travaux
fondateurs de la place la place ceci dit
en pratique il ne s'agit en fait
toujours pâle a de la considération
cruciale pour déterminer s'il faut
administrer un traitement un patient en
particulier de la performance moyenne
sur l'ensemble de la population mondiale
n'est pas ce qui devrait importer pour
un patient donné car aucun patient n'est
une moyenne de la population mondiale
chaque individu a des spécificités
physiologique et social comment son âge
son sexe et son état de santé actuel est
un bon bayésiens pragmatique se doit de
tenir compte de ces données pourrait
estimer la balance risque/bénéfice pour
cet individu en particulier pour
adresser la complexité des spécificités
individuelles des modèles beaucoup plus
sophistiqués sont nécessaires c'est
d'ailleurs vers cette question que se
dirige la recherche sur les effets des
vaccins astrazeneca sur les troubles de
coagulation
plus précisément il s'agit de déterminer
les profils physiologique pour
lesquelles ce risque pourrait être
suffisamment important pour qu'il soit
préférable de rediriger les patients
avec ses profil physiologique vers
d'autres vaccins contre 19 qui n'ont pas
ces risques ceci étant dit même pour ses
modèles plus complexes de façon cruciale
l'apprentissage reste une danse chaque
données collectées pour d'autres
patients va affecter les crédences des
risques et des bénéfices des traitements
pour le patient à disposition il
pourrait être amené à prendre une bonne
décision
il est utile de bien faire tous les pas
de danse qui permettent d'affiner nos
crédence et de mettre à jour notre
multivers parisien pour ensuite prendre
la meilleure décision possible sachant
l'état de l'ensemble de nos
connaissances malheureusement effectué
les bons petits pas de danse est
extrêmement difficile surtout quand on
sait qu'on ne pourra pas tous les
effectuer à cause notamment de nos
limites cognitives
en fait le bavaisien pragmatique doit
faire encore plus attention à ses pas de
danse et prêter attention en particulier
au fait qui ne va pas
thierry pick n est pas de danse qui vont
systématiquement dans la bonne direction
en particulier un bien peut être très
largement convaincu 2 x et voir une
donnée qui est plutôt compatible avec
nos os x si c'est le cas il devra alors
faire un petit pas vers non x10 bien sûr
si c'est un petit pas ça veut pas la
nier complètement vers knicks bref danse
est un art délicat le plutôt que d'y
voir une corvée je vous invite à monter
le volume et à trouver du plaisir
lorsque vous mettrez en secret le
postérieur
[Musique]